all right big big news if you go to
christy comedy.com you'll see it we have
added a third live hey babe show august
25th 6 p.m royersford pennsylvania also
september 17th 18th fort lauderdale
florida dania improv also september 24th
to the 26th this is a huge one irvine
improv irvine california los angeles
area i'm finally coming out there it's
going to be good i might have special
guest westies all our favorite
podcasters from the west coast told me
they'd like to come in and be with mr
chrissy chaos because we're gonna get
wild hopefully someone will piss on the
audience or piss in my mouth irvine
california september 24th to the 26th
christy comedy.com for tiki wikis
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe
pot back again
doing a little east coast swing
hey baby pot going off
not too hard
not too soft hey babe hey babe how you
doing i am pretty hard right now yeah
i'm not too soft either so okay so
so let me tell you this yes so the plane
yes
takes off about takeoff jams on the
brakes the pilot two things the pilot
was a female gets on says we're sorry
we're sorry we have a problem in the
back of the plane all of a sudden you
hear a guy screaming i ain't gonna put
on my mask i ain't gonna put on my mask
screaming whatever going crazy one of
the passengers had to hold i think it
was all like a family or friend group
had to hold him in his seat until he got
back
to the drawbridge to the thing it was
dude it was
tell me they at least kicked him off and
you took the flight oh yes they
eventually took the flight but
we kicked the guy they kicked the guy
off the plane like in in handcuffs like
i've never seen that but i've never seen
this either which i was like oh god but
whatever it happened i saw in my own
eyes
the the pilot both both the the pilot
was a female and the first maid or first
captain whatever they're both females so
they both come out and say we're sorry
you know
sorry for the incidents we're gonna try
to make up time in the air you know as a
constellation whatever it's going to be
free alcohol on the plane so plane
starts clap or whatever a guy like two
rows behind me starts getting his bag
gets off he goes i'm not going to fly
women are flying and i swear to god gets
off gets off the plane
he didn't say that to me or anyone but
under his breath like two separates i'm
not flying if there's women flying the
plane i'm not doing this and then gets
off it was like 11 30 at night i was
like this guy's not going to get on a
flight again until tomorrow like and i
i'm not lying it couldn't have been a
smoother flight when we landed in jfk it
was like those ones where you don't even
know you don't even know dude it might
have been the easiest flight i've ever
been on in my life it was like
but i've never seen that happen ever guy
come control we were literally
accelerating and then they hit the
brakes that guy that guy's bold that
means he's never going to fly in a
flight with a female pilot which is
interesting he hasn't done it before
that's what i'm saying he probably has
what an idiot i was like how do you know
was he alone yeah yeah he was alone can
you imagine taking a
oh so dumb i mean i was like there must
have been plenty of times where you've
flown you couldn't you didn't know as a
woman because maybe she has a deep voice
it's like hey this is i'm like i'm
welcome i'm your pilot but her name's
really she did a video of the guy last
week that was like screaming and
everyone he got like i guess he got
drunk a young kid and i was like you're
my parents it was like the typical
douche chills like when someone's
yelling you don't know who i am you know
who my parents are
he went i think he even went to his
grandparents wow he screamed he goes a
few people he goes my parents are worse
i it's the weirdest flex ever like in
this day and age i mean don't get me
wrong it's a lot of money but it's not
like
full-on fu
money my parents all worth about two
million dollars
it was half of it
i i watched it i was like
you feel like my parents own
you know owned patel yes my parents
owned sabaro yeah
well my parents are worth 50 million he
was like my parents are i have a net
value of 2 million
or you might even sell my grandparents
and he goes my grandparents can buy any
of you it's like for two million i don't
know and then he just wouldn't stop
apparently he grabbed a uh uh he groped
a flight attendant
and he was and so they he was drawing
then he started screaming at him and
then
they go and they go to get him and he
swings at the flight attendant they
tackle him and then they
for the rest of the flight they duct
tape him no to his chair and then they
duct tape his mouth
and the whole plane has their their
cameras on with their lights on and
they're just recording his face
in mid-air and he's getting duct tape
around his mouth he's stuck he's duct
taped in here and they're just recording
him and everyone's like you [ __ ]
if you told me that that was going to
happen i genuinely i would have paid a
thousand dollars to get on that too just
to see it and i'll tell you another
thing i heard that is the airline was
frontier and i guess that wasn't
protocol to duct tape him to his chair
and so the the um the flight attendants
are currently suspended no you can't
suspend them you can't do you have the
video of them being duct taped
i'd love to see a minute long video but
okay funniest thing here we go frontier
airlines passengers saw ufc fly that's
the thing with flight attendants they're
trained to know how to fight and subdue
you yeah if when you talk to flight
attendants like i don't know if you've
ever like had a few drinks and like
started talking to the flight attendant
they all have horror stories they all
they all deal with because you know
being up in the air like you know the
chances you've seen something like that
are slim but they're they're flying
every day every day they see wild wild
alcohol
yeah these are all the news clips though
wow it's out there it's it's it's it's i
saw like that's the only one i could
click on for a while is a minute and two
jesus i've never
even like as soon as you talk tell me
like there was one time where i got
really angry on video pimp yeah
it was one time
i was really i forgot what happened like
you know whatever just stress eating
stress flying or whatever and i was like
and stress eating i was like i was like
you know said something to a flight
attendant where i was like you know i
don't you know i was getting angry at
them or some for some stuff and they
were like sir like
like do you want do you do you want us
to like have to land the plane and get
you off this and i said absolutely not
like i just sat right down i was like
that's all you have to tell me so i
would never i would never get to this
like you have to be ossified drunk yeah
yeah
you guys
[ __ ] shot
i mean he's not wrong there i don't know
if frontier airlines is number one
two million goddamn dollars
the guy's taper yeah
my grandpa's worth more than your life
i mean this is i will now i will now
only fly frontier airlines
i changed my whole opinion
the whole plane is videotaping him
getting duct taped
that's amazing
dude
that is what do you serve that kid that
he's like my grandpa
is worth more than your life uh he even
said my parents are worth
over two he said over it he goes my
grandparents are worth
over two million dollars over what a
douche idiot i think rich kids rich kids
are a little wild i'm pro bringing the
stockade back me too cursing people do
it
you know what i'm proud to like if you
commit a crime that's like you know not
anything horrible like you do something
i don't know steal something or
something
you get tarred and feathered they used
to tar that literally used to be a
legitimate and punishment colonel you
walked around with wearing that your
little phone mike your little thing
they would stop us they would say um
they would say your what your punishment
was specifically was you would to be
tarred and feathered in a public swear
square so they would take you to the
public square but it actually hurt
because they were it was like burning
hot
hot tar like they're they would that
damaged shout out all forms of torture
oh my god yeah
tar and feather that was a big one yeah
what about um um when they tile or every
limb to a horse and their horses just
run in different directions yeah but
that would kill you yeah this i'm
talking about like stockade tar and
feather these things that they wouldn't
kill you but it was just like a form of
punishment
is the original viral video that's
embarrassing yeah right truly yeah right
about the full town lineup for like
purple nurples and wet willies that's
well that's what they george washington
that's what they did yeah they're
nervous you would get everybody would
get could you imagine that like
literally like you go back in time and
your control and that's the punishment
you give everybody
what sucks worse than a purple nurple
anything
it's funny to call a nipple and nurple
my nervous system
oh my god what a set of nerves oh wow
look at this guy got purple
oh my god this kid got nervous he got
purpley nerdy this kid
wow that's my nerves look at his nerves
oh my god you guys ever had someone
scream do you know who i am at you
i think i probably haven't probably have
can i call it up immediately
no i'll never forget the worst one i had
i was i had to fill in as like oh you
used to work in the hamptons filling in
the hamptons is like a bouncer for a
night and some guy was so drunk they
said don't let him in i didn't let him
in and he goes you know what this means
to me and he took out a hundred dollar
bill and ripped it in my face as if i
was aggravated and he said that's what
it means and i was like wow
that's not i mean just wasted that's
also i think it might be a felony
so you can't destroy legal tender stuff
are you real is that true you can't
deface it or destroy it you can't
destroy it right now have you burned
like a dollar bill right now on air i
think you'd have a case against you
really yeah you can't destroy legal
tender
section 333 of us criminal code whoever
mutilates cuts defaces disfigures or
perforates or unites or cements together
or does any other thing to any bank bill
draft or note or other evidence of debt
issued by any national banking
association or federal bank reserve and
then it just stops just stops it's
technically illegal to deface u.s
currency to the point at which it's
rendered unusable
okay
but
so the general so the first rip of the
bill in half is illegal but the
subsequent hundred rips it becomes legal
again so my question is that guy who
ripped a hundred dollar bill if i was
there and said you're now under arrest
citizens citizens
but what if he said but wait a second i
could scotch tape and you can still
clearly see the serial numbers it's
rendered unusable do would we have to go
to the bank and say before you arrest me
you have to legally confirm that this is
rendered unusable well in my days
working at delicatessen's delivery
services and bars
sometimes people will give me taped
money which is and the the line is
you know as long as you can the serial
numbers match it's legal you gotta take
it people used to say that you know you
gotta take it
i i if it was ripped but like a serial
number was off they'd be like as long as
you could match the two you got to take
it it's like when people like you got to
tell me if you're a cop yeah so they
would always say you got to take it i
don't know i guess one time i did a gig
one time i did a gig and i got paid i
got paid it was only like i think like
120 bucks something like that but anyway
the hundred dollar bill was fake i
didn't know that it was fake and i went
to the atm
to put the money in and it's a big
problem because i put the fake 100 and i
had no idea and it sent some type of
alert the bank tellers came out and were
like uh is there a problem with the atm
i said yeah like you know keeps giving
back to 1000. bill and they got in they
said this is fake this is bogus money
where did you get this and i told them i
did a gig or whatever and they said okay
and i had to fill out all the i had to
fill it like like a like a couple of
pages worth of paperwork saying that
that they took it for me but it's not
like i got a hundred dollars they were
like i'm sorry like you lost so i called
the venue and they were like no that
can't be true and i was like i genuinely
just gave a fake hundred dollar bill and
they're like well then mo you and i gave
them my venmo and i still to this day
never got the money i was in a bar one
time with my friends and it was a guy
there that we kind of that we knew
actually and he was buying do we still
know him
do i know you don't know him okay you
don't know no no it's not like that he's
from old from the neighborhood it's like
a guy that but you know but right it
wasn't like two people wasn't somebody
everybody knew it was no it wasn't like
steven seagal no no no no okay me and
the two people
anyway he was very very nice kid very
friendly sweet person he's buying gay
baby not gay okay buying everyone in the
bar drinks right just throwing the money
around
and like two hours later we looked up
and there was a cop car outside and they
were cuffing him against it it was all
it was fake he was using fake money wow
and he was like not hiding it he was
buying for everyone
it was like he was really flaunting but
to getting cuffed for that like it must
have been like if you have
time to just realized
and he was paying all night and called
he alerted them then they came
interesting to see the money and they
they arrested him they faked it wow
a little fakey
most states authorize private citizens
to make arrests if the suspect has
actually committed a felony was
committing a breach of the peace
misdemeanor in the presence of the
citizen i want to say in my life i'd
like to make a citizen's arrest would
you
if you've ever made a citizen's arrest
sound off in the comments sound off in
the comments let us know if you've ever
made a citizen's arrest everybody know
what you're what can we do can i arrest
you right now
if you get out of line with me
right now i think in a way that i feel
threatened or that you're doing
something you shouldn't be doing what do
i do subdue you i think if you can
subdue me and you can prove you can
arrest me i think you could probably
take a bunch of if i try to subdue you
and you resist are you resisting
citizen's arrest
i think i am i don't know what the
penalty for that is but i think yeah i'm
resisting a citizen's arrest because as
a private citizen if another citizen
wants to arrest me and i don't really
understand the scope of what a citizen's
arrest entails i'm going to be opposed
to that just based on the fact that i
don't know if they know what their
jurisdiction actually is right so then
would it be illegal for me to resist a
citizen's arrest also how about this how
about this what about this i'm a citizen
does that give me jurisdiction in all 50
states because a lot of times police
officers can't make an arrest and cross
the state lines i got a new york state
license can i make a citizen's arrest in
new jersey or will not be upholded by
the new jersey governors i think we put
down we pause right now we go outside we
our citizen arrests somebody right now
somebody we citizen arrest somebody
right now we subdue them we call the
cops we see what they say we come back
and report back to the party
yeah how about this my daughter you know
to be funny ripped up a dollar bill the
other day can i make a citizen to rest
on her you should arrest her i'm going
to arrest people young when i get home
she's getting arrested for defacing us
u.s currency especially in times like
this it is already divided enough yeah
actually we were part of a citizen's
arrest i'm just reading the
technicalities of it when that guy peed
on that woman oh my dude i was with
brendan schaub i worked with brendan by
the way brendan sharp can i just tell
you he's already talked about this on
his podcast but brandon shop you know
friend of the show great comic you know
xmma fighter great comic brendan shaw we
all know him king and sting i actually
don't know brendan you know brendan i
mean i know of him of course and i think
i've met him a couple times said hello
but i don't know him personally brendan
good guy cauliflower both ears very
scary very intimidating um the thick boy
he
he i we did a show this is these are his
back-to-back gigs
the first one we were there homeless pip
and i were there with the haha comedy
club in l.a he just wanted to do a quick
little run there so we go do the haha
comedy club in la
i was worked on the show with them it
was fun i go on stage having a great
time you know fine brendan goes on stage
the man
somebody in the front row gets up in the
middle of his set turns around and begin
proceeds to urinate all over the table
behind him he hadn't been served one
drink all night they would give him
waters all night he he peed all over the
people right behind him he took out his
penis penis and started urinating on a
group of all girls he pissed on the
whole table at like a ten top with
different parties yes and then pissed on
this one woman was he with anyone no he
was his girlfriend he was with his
girlfriend so was he just drunk from
before he entered it seemed like pills
or pills
so he goes and what did his girlfriend
do she i guess was furious god bless oh
she did she stood up for him okay
because
i mean brandon was on stage and had to
deal with it because a fist fight pretty
much broke out right and then they they
they couldn't get the kid out of the
room he wouldn't leave the room
i told him the whole thing it was in our
new vlog you got to be kidding me yeah
so what happened
so they go to make the comedy club call
the police
they the people of the club held him
there
citizens arrested people saying in the
alleyway behind the club the police get
there
decide not to press charges and they let
them go why we don't know
they just didn't want to deal with it
what happened to all the urine
they came and cleaned it up well to
brendan's credit he dealt with it lovely
he because it was obviously like a 15
minutes you got to make it about he
didn't stop the show he kept going with
his own material yeah well you know
you're not just digging into what's
happening no he did no no that's what
i'm saying to his credit he did well
okay being able to maneuver into what
was happening get the crowd back
material i thought he would do pretty
well who's the staffer who has to clean
the i filmed her clean the piss during
the set
no
got pissed on and i got them to meet
brendan and chris out back and talk yeah
so that's on my youtube youtube.com says
christy comedy i didn't even know that
okay so we got that but but did wait but
but then they sat people back down at
the piss table they got moved to vip
moved to vip vip vipp oh vip yeah in the
haha
there was a vip section that was not
that was available but so yeah so if you
get peed on that we have a vip but then
if you want to sit in the pit seats it's
vi the vip
so so that that's that don't sit there
after that
i mean what what exactly are you white
you can't challenge with you
yeah i look like windex but interesting
fact they sat the next show didn't
mention it interesting which is what
happens
so you raise hepatitis c you have to sit
and ask yourself how many restaurants
have we sat in the couple before the
table for was piston wow
so people could be people
lucky he got away with that i mean
literally they were before the cops got
there they were talking about not only
like a misdemeanor like a felony like uh
like sexual assault
like a whole thing like you exposure
well you were there right i was there
what was the girlfriend or the man
saying in the moment the man wasn't
saying anything like that he's on video
he was babbling he was out of his mind
he might have been people just started
screaming he actually tried to go into
the green room and they had to remove
him from the ground so so that
but in that moment he commanded the
whole audience
the eyes when someone stands and then
someone's like what are you doing
people screaming like the way the comedy
club is configured you wouldn't be able
to tell that he's peeing you've been a
comedy club in l.a yeah really yeah
interesting yeah there's the bar out
front yes yes then you go and it's it's
really dark it's got a neon yes css yeah
yeah yeah yeah i did a spot there once
so
no it's interesting because a lot of
people because people are just trying to
do the club again now people are just i
didn't like all the people i talked to
like oh we never used to do haha but now
it's getting like a resurgence yeah yeah
so it was i did it years but this is
this is but it was like sexual assault
they had citizen arrested him yeah and
then the cops were like cops let them go
well that said citizen arrest right i
get that like i've seen someone maybe
like assault someone and then a bunch of
people held them down until the cops
came i guess that's a citizen's arrest
that is a civ no that is because
you're detaining them because what what
am i going to do assistant arrest i'm
not going to arrest you and then load
you into the back of my toyota and then
put you in jail in my basement right you
know like i think the citizens arrest is
i am subduing you until i call the
actual authorities okay
if you're carrying a credit balance
month after month it could feel like
you're a never-ending cycle of debt
upstart helps you make that final
payment so you can get ahead so many
americans experienced financial hardship
in the last year upstart can help you
regain your footing and get things back
on track so you don't have to get beat
up with somebody wearing a track suit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
with a five minute online rate check you
could see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars if you wanna go sixty thousand
dollars you can go
up starts one thousand and fifty
thousand so find out how upstart
colonial monthly payments today when you
go to
upstart.com hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe don't forget to use the url to
let them know we
sent you you understand yes so if you
get money from upstart you better use
our code so upstart knows that we send
you to them that's how this all works
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information providing your loan up
application go to
upstart.com so when i look at you i can
literally just see your multivitamins
going down your entire body i'm tracing
them with my eyes babe coursing them
through my veins how how am i doing that
i use ritual that's why you use rituals
so that's how and those are the vegan
friendly multivitamins formulated with
high quality nutrients in bioavailable
forms your body can actually use right a
hundred percent and also they are
traceable my friend do you understand
what that means
yes the cdc can trace them
you'll always know what nutrients you're
taking and where they come from thanks
to rituals one of a kind visible supply
chain you'll always always know you
already read that part now they're
available for women men and teens okay
ritual multivitamins are scientifically
developed to help support different life
stages so it doesn't matter if you're
two years old or or your cain tanaka you
can take rituals as long as you got
teeth shout out kane tanaka yeah get key
nutrients without the bs rituals
offering our listeners ten percent off
during your first three months visit
ritual dot com slash hey babe to start
your ritual today simple enough if you
don't take a multivitamin you should be
and and if you and and so then why not
try ritual why not try rituals let us
know how it is everything should be
doing everybody should be doing uh you
know cause i've been taking my
multivitamins with too much bs this is
bs free that's right ritual so what's
the promo code one more time
or that website what is it ritual ritual
dot com slash hey babe to start your
ritual today that's ritual.com hey babe
you're gonna get 10 off during your
first three months they shipped the
multi-vs right to you so you could stick
your p or v on your multi-v and it'll be
good ritual dot com slash hey babe 10
off during your first three months
okay let's see it let's okay
right now babes let's make okay you take
you put on the glasses you take it
making a citizen's arrest if you decide
to make a citizen's arrest you should
one tell the suspect plainly that you
are making a citizen's arrest and that
you are holding him or her or that are
they until police arrive
okay
call the police okay ask
lexplicitly yes what's the word
ex
laxy ask lasticity elasticity yeah ask
lactose explicitly for his or her
cooperation and so it's like i am
holding you here i will be holding you
here i am going to call the police do i
have your cooperation yes
i start reading the miranda rights
avoid using force if possible and use it
to minimum possibilities what am i
supposed to hypnotize them yeah like i'm
holding you here with my words
photography
[Laughter]
my word
stay there stay police do you agree
i have someone here he's agreeing to
stay
do not question or search the suspects
your purpose is only to temporarily
detain when police arrive state the
plain facts of what happened when i but
i want to know
when you're allowed to do that
like if i see someone jaywalk
if i see someone litter yeah because i
see that all the time and i want to kill
those people yeah can i think you can i
think you can i don't it doesn't say
what the crime has to be
now the police could very well get there
and let them go as what happened at the
hahahaha right
because the people they said listen you
paid to sit down vip this is what
happens
i got a spot tonight you know uh it'd be
like where where are you playing
um i got a spot tonight where you going
[Laughter]
club
and it was like eleven halls and you're
like oh my god
club i love that place yeah
so that leads me to my next thing yeah
so that's brendan sham's first gig the
very next weekend
next gig so you go from vip more piss
plus tell me it's more sitting in the
green room
sitting in the green room yeah man
charges into the green room with a knife
and tries to kill brendan shaw and his
brother
i swear you were there no no no i was
told about it brendan shop has to burrow
through
break down the door i believe it's
tacoma comedy club or yeah bro the only
way out of that groom is onto the stage
has to break and and shoulder down the
door and come out onto stage while a
live show is happening say there's a man
in the green room trying to kill me
we'll be back in a moment you got to be
kidding me i swear brendan has talked
about on his pocket with a knife brendan
told me the story and i couldn't un
believe it what was happening he goes
they originally thought he had a gun so
his brother who was like his tour
manager i guess says
we need to get out of this green room we
need to get out of this green room right
now that guy has a gun he's coming
towards grooming wants to kill us so
they burrow through the door brendan
said if i would have known it was a
knife i would have known i could just
take this guy down and get the knife
it's me and his brothers sure or he's
you know he's a he's an mma fighter his
brother's a big guy but a knife is also
a knife a knife is a knife with someone
who's a lunatic yeah so okay what what
mixed but he literally no there was a
guy on stage meaning and brendan schaab
the headliner there to see burrows
through the door the crowd starts
applauding thinking it's part of the
show and they said no no there's a man
trying to kill me
like bursting
could you imagine those are back-to-back
gigs you got vipb and then somebody
tries to kill you
did you get any uh any extra information
on this person the police came he was
arrested that was not a citizen's arrest
so the club held him and he actually was
arrested because he tried to kill the
headliner which i guess is a bigger deal
than trying to pee on the ladies behind
you so he tried to kill the headless his
motivation
you have to ask i don't know what his
motivation was i actually i brendan said
he doesn't know that but again brendan
just continued the show okay so i'm just
gonna ask questions based on this and
you might not have the answers but if he
didn't know but what did he know
all he knew was did he so he didn't see
a gun or a blade no but did a person
make a threat out loud an audible threat
i believe his brother who's also a very
big guy his brother's a very big guy he
looks just like brennan but has a very
small head it's very interesting to look
at him he's got a tiny head but such a
nice guy they call him lenny from of
mice and men and that fits okay so
so he he um subdued the guy
they subdued the guy
i believe his brother did and then
called the police and the police came
and like brendan was uh
you know eventually able to uh uh to
keep going on the show but my question
to brendan was because they have a guy
they call kentucky who's who films all
his content and i said that's gonna be
great for the vlog he said kentucky did
kentucky didn't get it he put his camera
down and ran i said when i have to fire
kentucky kentucky i said because guess
what i said because guess what if that
was homeless pimp would homeless pimp be
dead right now sure he would but would i
have fire content on my blog you bet
your ass i would yes we'd have fire
content on the block yeah you know
homeless pimp missed a shot in his past
yes his name used to just be pimp yes
and then he got fired and then he became
homeless
that's why he's called homeless but i
said literally homeless people would be
bleeding out of his carotid right now
but you better believe he'd have a
subtitle clip ready to go for it
i'll take a bullet for the vlog for the
vlog i love the post shop made about it
tacoma comic club you break it to a
green room with a knife and you see this
what do you do true story that happened
last night i mean to be honest with
these three cute kids i might jump right
in your lap
and lay right across i mean brenton i
mean dude i i don't know i see though if
i'm walking into a green room with a
knife and i see those three people
nothing really changes for me i still
yeah you understand i'd say i'm not all
there i mean i have a knife you don't
most likely i'd say the voices in my
head are still telling me to kill
everyone in here was this guy trying to
like rob material
i don't know what he was trying to do i
i genuinely don't know what he was
trying to do
i have no idea
i have you know everybody at brenda's
like dude this guy's been using my
material all the time yeah get the buddy
what happened he was now he just came in
one night knife point robbed me of my
joke oh my jokes he said i have to give
him up
wow
yeah so that is um those are you know
crazy i had people get arrested of
having sex at our show once i told you
that no
no sorry in florida yeah people just i
didn't know at a joker show i saw a
commotion yeah at the hard rock
saw a come on
yeah saw a commotion and then afterwards
people were like yeah people
decided to start having sex in like the
last row i guess you guys are like
going doggy what reverse cowgirl what
were they doing i think that she was
sitting on him
got it which i would no do you agree
with them getting thrown out for that
indeed it's a family show it is a family
shop not really i mean it's like i think
it's 18 and i was 18 and older or
whatever it is yeah or 16 and older is
there is there one can they bring hits
yeah because we don't make it a hard and
fast rule because what happens is nobody
reads the goddamn rules and then they
show up with like inevitably out of all
the people people show up families and
kids sure and then it's like a whole
commotion having to turn people away you
don't want to turn away
so we say 16 plus suggested and then
like sometimes if there's kids right up
front i'll just like it's the first
thing i'll do is address it sure of
course just let you know you know you
have cool parents you brought them here
but [ __ ] piss
and i just get it all out of the way
just letting you know this is fine but
one of the you know some of the members
of our staff aren't legally not allowed
to be within 100 feet of you
so if you want to move back um so but
but but that's interesting because i'm
i'm on the fence if they were in the
front row for sure but if they were in
the back row not necessarily bothering
anyone but you can't but yeah but world
rules apply
in the venue do you know you can't just
and you just can't penetrate someone in
front of other people do you know that
there's i think it's the buffalo bills
there's a guy's full job shout out tom
brady though by the way yeah shout out
to shout out tom brady in the bucks at
least if you're talking about the
football how can you not mention they've
won the super bowl they just want
they're just saying
the nfl and you know pastor mohammed
kansas city chiefs runner-up thank god
for him great great great career ahead
of him it's congrats to him the whole
institution over there 100 big things
big big things
the bills buffalo bills there's a guy
who's full job
his only job is to go around the parking
lot and break up people having sex the
buffalo bills fan base the bills
build mafia the absolute lexicity of him
to be able to do that i mean it'd be
hard for me to do that yeah i'd be hard
doing it
he could go up go around and break up
break up people having sex tap on the
shoulder you don't necessarily get
thrown out of orchard park which is
where you're kidding me yeah his job is
to do the bill's mafia there's nothing i
don't know if it still is but i remember
seeing something somewhere that that was
his job and he had to because the bill's
mom like when you go to a when you go to
a buffalo bills game and you tailgate in
the parking lot you have to prepare to
have a limb broken like they go
[Music]
that's his company i mentioned it once
in a while anyway you know there my
cousin mike's a bills fan he tells me
all about the bill's mafia i heard it's
crazy party
can i just tell you something yeah you
don't think that it's a little strange
like how our brains like how how did i
know to bring up the buffalo bills and
the person who is the bills fan shirt
you're wearing i don't know
my cousin mike who's really like my
brother is a huge bills fan his brother
danny has a place called red seal gaming
that i mentioned before where they do no
it's not a ball it's blown off the
moment
it ball's blown
is it a bbo i like the connection so
it's not a bbl bb bb it's not going off
yeah it's it's not it's not necessarily
a bbo
it's a
it's a bulls ko it's a ball it's a bka
my balls were knocked around balls
knocked around so yeah so i'd like to
for you guys just go to the hey go email
heybaypodcastgmail.com and tell us your
best bbl moments yeah tell us the last
time you got your bees blown oh yeah and
also we should do a live podcast from
that parking lot with those insane
people i'd love to i'll tell you what i
wonder if it's my job if that's weird
because is he like
paying attention
for penetration throughout the stands
because then he's the weirdo or is it
just like is he just going to when
people see someone penetrating they're
like
yeah yeah
and then he knows where to go he knows
where to go because because i would
think if there was a guy i know if i was
a buffalo bill's quota if there was a
guy whose job that was i would feel as a
fan it's my job to have sex in the
parking lot and see if i can get away
with it that's what that would feel like
yeah you're tempting the masses you're
adding attempting the mafia i mean what
do you think i'm going to say dude the
badge of honor yeah i just had i got
thrown out by the sex guy for having sex
in the parking lot i am now officially
that might be the only way you get
inducted into the building captain i'm
the capitan yeah team captain
speaking of god i had a a couple of
weeks ago because i i wasn't around last
week or the week before when you and joe
did the thing yes i had ended on a cliff
you ended on a cliff
i was telling you i was at this crazy
party in london a a brunch with a bunch
of crazy crazy guests right right to
recap we walk into this place we got
invited to it was this weekly brunch at
this estate where they have
they host these parties and known for it
and i told you it was just like
an insane
home
and woody harrelson was there
and uh liv tyler
and
liam gallagher from oasis
uh
owen wilson
and i think willie nelson wow yeah
amongst like 15 other people right and
us and you're just tricking mimosas and
and eating brunch and talking to these
people i didn't know that they were
going to be there
woody harrelson and owen wilson all
these people they were in
in the uk
about to film a movie i forget what it's
called woody harrison's movie the whole
movie was
filmed
live
the 90-minute movie was filmed live and
streamed live to movie theaters so when
you were sitting in the theater which i
did and you were watching the movie they
were filming it in that moment live
streaming how is that even possible they
went out there and they literally
rehearsed it for like months and months
and months
and then that was it if they messed up
they messed up did they mess up there
was like one or two messed up did you
catch it i i didn't catch it but
afterwards there was a q a
and and they they called out like the pl
the guy felt terrible like some guy left
the scene too early and came back but
they covered it up well enough that you
didn't know but then after they told you
you realized oh [ __ ] that's probably
what happened i want to see this movie
what was the name of the movie um lost
in london boston london 2017
wow lost in the first film ever
broadcast live i was on tour and and now
so you were there on january 19th you
were in england i was
on tour there
if i
i might have i forget what theater i saw
it if i was in england or back home but
i was there they were there for that and
they were rehearsing that could you
imagine the pressure the pressure the
pressure
it's he's in every it's woody harrison
he's in every single scene for 90
straight minutes they get in a car they
go to multiple locations it's outside
inside it's in an apartment it's in a
nightclub it's yeah well why didn't they
follow him
i was gonna say what what if what if
what if he's not even like what if it's
not even up to the actual natchez what
if there's an explosion or the police
have to shut down a street 100 you just
got to deal with it what if you have a
sneezing fit you have to what if you
forget your line what if you need water
i know and they're all in it and they're
all in and they're just waiting on
stamina but i gotta watch this tonight
read read that read that the idea for
the film came to harrelson following a
night out in at china white a club in
soho which i don't know if it's soho
england or soho new york in 2002. he
broke an astra oh i guess soho london he
broke an ashtray in a london taxi which
led to remember this being chased by
police in a different taxi and spending
a night in jail
in the film harrelson wilson and nelson
play themselves in a story based on the
real event where harrison struggles to
get home while running into friends and
members of a royal family holy smokes
yeah and he ends up in jail too i'm
surprised this wasn't like a bigger deal
that everyone saw because it's so
mind-blowing it was wild maybe it's big
in the uk i don't know i remember
watching it like you know like that's
insane to watch like you just i was
hanging on every word by the way i'm i
don't like i know that there's
differences but from now on i'm not
going to go with the uk as much as i'm
going to go with great britain great
brits i'm going to say i'm in great
britain yeah i'd like to say that the
united kingdom the united kingdom is
great but i like great britain i know
that they may not be the exact same
thing but i'm saying if i got a show in
london yeah and you say chris where are
you going to be this weekend i said i'm
actually going to great britain it
sounds more distinguished i'm going to
great britain yeah yeah i got chosen
great britain but great britain is only
britain right great britain is a
geographic term referring to the island
also known simply as britain united
kingdom on the other hand is purely a
political term it's the independent
country that encompasses all of great
britain and the region now called
northern ireland
so if you're saying the united kingdom
you're implying more things so i
understand for that i wouldn't say if i
was in northern ireland i'm in great
britain because that's not you but if
i'm in england proper i'm gonna just
from now on say i'm in great britain and
i'm fine with that okay yeah just want
to make sure i want you to do it so
we're there yes and uh we go down and
there's a safe what's it called a safe
room yeah
yeah there's a good movie it's proper
it's like that it's like like thick wall
thing like i like that we're both saying
proper because we're in england we're
talking about english things so we're
saying it's proper yeah because because
in america if it was a panic room in
indiana you wouldn't say a proper panic
group no no you could say a freaking
indiana panic room yeah yeah but i like
this guy yeah and ipr yeah yeah so we
went so everyone's like oh so what are
your house and goes oh let's go play
some ping pong
so i'm like he says that to owen wilson
he goes come on let's go downstairs
everybody and you guys are just sitting
there minding you being yeah so i was
like all right i'm gonna go watch them
play ping so i go downstairs and there's
a ping pong you invited yourself down to
the ping pong ball everyone was hanging
out it was a party
so i was gonna say that's ballsy yeah no
but well i think they like what people
were playing and you could play i got
next yeah the hell like that i mean
because it'd be one of those things i'm
like listen guys i know you guys sold
out 10 shows at the o2 arena that
doesn't necessarily mean you can just
invite yourself to watch
anybody else and play ping pong i mean
who do you think you are
you're not the queen not at all not at
all i am a queen yeah the queen not the
queen yeah i no i was tiptoeing around i
wasn't like in there being like yeah
i'll come down and i was very like
reserved i'm shy as it is yeah so i i
make my way down in the panic room is
the ping pong table so now i'm in the
panic room and they're playing
competitive ping pong right like
they're both very good
woody harrison was especially good
almost was pretty good but like i think
woody harrison could have killed him but
they were they were better than i can't
like they were they were putting english
on it yeah you understand right so i'm
sitting there
on it they'll put some red hats
they're putting great british on that
yeah and uh like it was weird the cats
were walking around and i'm just people
are coming in and now the cats you mean
felines or like the cats like you're
calling people in there that are right
now i wasn't like getting like yeah you
mean that actual feline cats yeah
there's cat it's just weird i'm like i'm
in a panic room with two cats owen
wilson and and woody house and they're
playing competitive at a certain point i
might have been the only one in there
yeah at a certain point you might have
been like hey am i on mushrooms or is
this really happening i know and i'm
just watching them and i'm just like oh
good shot oh and we'll you know it's
just like this is weird anyway we leave
later i think we have a show that night
or something like that we leave the
party
they stay they keep drinking and
apparently they all tie one on and did
did i mention last week about how they
had the pool that that lowered i didn't
tell you this last night
i could have swore i did no no no no
well i would have remembered at one time
during the party the guy goes let me
show you something it's pretty cool and
in the middle of his home was a
courtyard and like the house wrapped
around it with all windows and he pushed
a button in the house and the cement
courtyard
lowered it down and as it started
lowering down from underneath the like
the house and underneath the line where
it went down water just starts shooting
out the thing lowers like eight feet and
it becomes a swimming pool on the fly
what and a big one like bigger than this
like this bigger than the size of this
like a real big ass pool
he goes there's only six in the world
the guy goes pushes the button the the
earth outside goes
it lows down and water just starts
filling in and within like five minutes
it was a full regular sized point it's a
water but my question would be wouldn't
the water not be clean and full of dirt
because it's coming down or is it just
i'm assuming it is held
in attack i don't know what the science
of it is
but it was the craziest thing i've ever
seen
it was it looked something like that but
it was outdoors
and is that going to lower down yeah
my question to you is though having a
pool in england is not the best idea
though right because it's never hot
there or does it get hot
i
for me i'm unclear about the weather
there right yeah and and the weather
patterns but it i feel like london fog
and here's here's knowing you knowing
you
you just saw that you just saw literally
literally a pool come out of the garden
floor i bet your first question to the
person next you would be like i wonder
if it's heated or not it is if it's not
i'm not going there it's not you're not
going down no that's impressive how many
there are because it's kind of like one
of those things where it's like you
gotta you literally moved your cement
floor to make a pool you can't run a gas
line into it you can heat it up it
better have all the amenities there's
only six in the world but there's no
heat right come on man we're in foggy
london i know also how long does it take
to load it wasn't long
it was like it was it was certainly
reasonable like 10 minutes five minutes
something like that
i watched it i watched it all happen i
don't really really because four years
ago i don't really really
do it just to be cooler did you guys
then get your swimsuits out i was like
holy [ __ ] so i leave i know about the
pool but later they keep drinking and
then the one of the people who invited
us to the home that lived there
texted us
not live tyler though no live there
someone who lived there okay texted us
the party was getting like a little bit
crazy at night and woody harrelson after
we told him about our show he's like oh
you guys are like do all that kind of
stuff you're kind of crazy like you know
you risk
he climbs onto the roof of the home and
then this is he's there to film this
live movie okay so if he hurts himself
that's bad that's not good he and he
does a back flip off of the roof of the
house he goes hey guys you think you're
crazy what you do watch this you're
seeing this live with your own i'm
seeing it on
and texted it to us because we left and
he just they all they got crazy and he
just was like you guys think you're
crazy watch us goes up climbs up the
ladder goes onto a roof goes on to the
top of the roof looks turns around does
a full back cliff off the roof of the
house and into the swimming pool if
the video of that could have truly
killed himself killed himself and he's
there to film the live movie if he would
have broke his leg his arm whatever his
neck that guy's that guy's a an og is
there any chance in hell you still have
that video
not that you would we could show it
anywhere but i just want to see it yes
it was texted to one of us so i i will
do i will do a hard search for that okay
i will text them and say somebody's got
to have that video because because
two things i love butchers and box
then you're gonna love hellofresh
[Laughter]
butcher box bunch of but you know how
much meat i got in this house
do you have any idea bro do you have any
idea once butcher box came on as a
sponsor shout out butcher box shout out
to box butcherbox.com do you know how
much meat i have at all times on or near
me i know for a fact you got so much
meat there's not a box big enough that
can take this meat you got to see how
much meat i got in near or around me at
all times let me see cuz you got 100
grass-fed finished beef you got
free-range organic chicken you got
humanely raised pork because i'm sick
and tired of you treating the pork like
pieces of [ __ ]
and they don't wild caught lobster tails
just the tails we catch the lobsters and
we just give you the tails wild caught
alaskan salmon and sugar nitrate free
bacon [ __ ]
each box ships what nine to 11 pounds of
meat pack fresh [ __ ] frozen vacuum
sealed making it simple to store in the
freezer and grab later for a delicious
meal with your friends i mean if butcher
box was around jeffrey dahmer wouldn't
have to have had to eat people made for
days you would have had yeah today's
sponsor butcher box wants to celebrate
you this summer so right now butcher box
offering new members two free lobster
tails and two free ribeyes in your box
and the delivery person shows up with
the meat hanging out of their box
butcherbox.com
hey babe if you want that deal go to
butcherbox.com hey babe free lobster
tails free rib eyes in your box boom two
five ounces and two ten ounces
only get this special deal when you sign
up for a new membership did you say all
that yeah butchbox.com says hey babe you
said that i said it all you said that
switchbox.com says hey babe put your box
on company babe go eat some box
this summer get the most out of your
travels abroad by learning the language
of your destination with babble the
number one selling language learning app
from ordering in restaurants or asking
directions
to gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture
babel makes the whole process of
learning a new language addictively fun
and easy with bite-sized lessons you can
actually use in the real world babel is
a can't miss travel essential
babbles 15-minute lessons making it the
perfect
which roughly translates to
the world is falling apart but babel
keeps me sane right right now
when you purchase a three-month babble
subscription you'll get
[Music]
that's b a b b e l dot com
code hey babe for an extra three months
free
but here's the thing that i'll argue
with that is because i am
i would be i would never do that but
whatever but there is a
thing where you say
you know big time athletes or like a
woody harrelson character like these
guys get so famous into the top of their
craft because they're truly fearless
like yeah he's truly like when you have
absolutely no inhibitions when you throw
them to the wind right you are con
you are designed for greatness yeah
you're designed for which i which and i
took that quote from ricky velez's
letter to stand up
right
shout out ricky velez it's got a
stand-up special good friend of the show
got a stand-up special coming out on hbo
august 20th right on man go to go if
you're in brooklyn area august 28th go
get tickets ricky velazquez now are you
guys panicking congrats that's awesome
what are you guys panic room guys like
would you ever consider it how'd it feel
i um
i
i am considering one really it felt good
why it felt good when you were in it
um
it didn't feel like anything the door
was open why are you considering i felt
like a room
it looks like a regular room you know
it's just that i think it can close with
like a door that is super thick and
can't be shot through or what have you
but why you could but but but is there a
way what if you got locked in there
though or does it have wi-fi
i would imagine this you know
that all that is pre-thought out
okay now why are you considering the
panic room
um you know because i i'm a panicky
with your panic room because if you had
a panic room when i
yeah like if i'm really panicking i
would just say let me know i'm watching
a playoff game and it's it's it's tough
i'll just go in there like myself in
there watch the panic room yeah yeah
yeah yeah when you get one we have to
not tell chris and lock him in because
that's the difference my new house has a
sunroom salesman has a panic room
no like
if
if and when i move uh and i go into a
home it's not if sal it's when sure sure
i was considering one only because i got
spooked and i saw like a dock or
something about like home invasions and
stuff and i'm just like in my head i'm
like
all right you're never prepared for a
home invasion and you never think a home
invasion is going to happen to you and
if one ever did happen to you what's the
[ __ ]
what name all your regrets you know
all right if i can
repurpose it but it has the ability to
lock people in there and keep them safe
i mean what's the big deal i'll just
like you know i'll it'll look like a
room
but it'll just say it's nvd to get a
panic room for you it's an nbd not a
bail no no don't get one get a pr
i don't even mean because of me
i'm saying i just mean like
at any point if someone came into your
house unsuspecting and they were they
had a weapon or anyone for anyone i just
like why not why not stack the deck
against the home invasion well like
right now like let's say somebody burst
into the studio and what are we gonna do
throw a microphone at them we can't do
anything no we would need brendan shobb
and the two black gentlemen that was
sitting on the couch with him that's
what we do that's what we need we'll
just do free reads for them yeah yeah
yeah i would literally start shouting
out promo codes
yeah
we could try to citizens arrest them but
we could try the citizen's arrest
i mean we could try to give him a
citizens arrest i wonder yeah you know
if anyone
go no i'm saying do a citizen's arrest
of your attempted murder if somebody's
trying to murder you and you citizens
arrest them do you know by the way
if you because i learned this in the
movie uh liar liar if you
if you
rob come into my house and try to rob me
and then you fall and hurt yourself
because if something you're no way
it was in liar liar with jim carrey
okay she goes
and literally in one of the scenes do
you think that's
legally clad yeah his assistant like you
know the elderly woman i forgot her name
but she goes he sued my friend he sued
my friend and because of guys like you
he won
yeah right yeah because you know jim
carras being a bad you know a dirty
lawyer right so the short answer is yes
can a burglar sue for personal injury it
is possible to sue for almost anything
though many claims will be dismissed as
frivolous
and die to burp and may cost those
attempting to litigate the issue for
both their own court costs and the cost
of those they intended to sue frivolous
is not a word i use much either yeah the
frivolity of the situation it also makes
me every time i say frivolous it makes
me think of shrimp fraud diablo
some type of weird dna
fr shrimp fried diablo
diablo
frivolous fruit
yeah um i would like to put like a
window in the panic room okay like
that's you know bulletproof that they
can't break so that once i'm in there
and the person's on the other side they
could just mock them unmercifully i mean
dude literally they even put a pa system
outside where i flip a switch pick up a
mic and just start roasting roasted up
you dumb idiot you didn't think i had a
panic room you didn't think i had a
panic room look at this guy yeah hey you
know
you know
just just start just going in on his
weight yeah
and as soon as and then your family life
you could call you know you have like
full action there's a landline in there
there's wi-fi and then you just start
playing what you got the cops on what
you're gonna do when they come for you
bad boy and then you're dancing around
you're right there you get butt starch
butt naked yeah you're talking out of
your butt like like ace
[Music]
in your house play the other jokers
laughing
or it's homeless pimp slap just right
all the door's locked he's in and the
house says the house is making the
citizens arrest you can't get out
i want this to happen i want to do it
yeah i would love to do it what if you
lock the burglar in the panic room
that'd be sick that would be amazing
then they can't get out of it yeah
now it's like shooting burglars in a
panic room what if i put a just a jail
cell if i ever have a new house just put
a jail cell in it i would lo and you
throw a noise into the jail cell yeah
annoying guests
rowdy children they get thrown into the
jail cell uh burglars sal you got listen
you got the you got the creativity you
got the ingenuity you got the mind i
would say you want to put a jail cell in
a panic room in there put it in yeah i
put a mcdonald's in too
just like richie rich put a mcdonald's
in could we do that why not could we get
a mcdonald's in all like didn't someone
have a starbucks in their home yeah if
you're staffing it it was on like i was
on like architectural digestion i mean
you're going to lose you're going to
lose money you're going to lose money if
you don't have you know i don't know if
you can allow people onto the property i
mean i guess as long as they show a vax
card yeah
that'd be great to ask her out like a
burglar for a vax card yeah
well yeah i i opened oh here we go can
you go up pimpy i think i just saw it i
opened up a starbucks in my house it
says
go down a little bit a little bit um uh
one more yeah i opened my own starbucks
at home
oh that's just a little kid okay those
kids make money i thought somebody had a
starbucks a famous person by the way you
want to talk about starbucks in their
house i want to talk about who the real
clowns and losers are please are me and
you yeah and everybody who's not who's
not a 10 year old kid on youtube because
they're making i mean 20 30 million
dollars they would have multiple panic
rooms multiple jail cells in their house
but we're over here thinking we're doing
the lord's work when it's like this 10
year old kid it's like i'll open up a
starbucks in my house right now i won't
even miss the money yeah famous we
should oh would you you want to do a
content house i want to i had the idea i
had the idea for a content house
in
stop yeah 2003 yeah me and the guys were
like let's all move into a house we'll
we'll we'll you know have cameras
everywhere and we'll just pump out
material all the time why don't you do
it content house
we used to call it sketch house sketch
house yeah sketch house
we said it for years we go guys let's do
it and then we would say one two three
we'll go sketch house
which sounds german but that's amazing
and in alternate reality you guys are
like the paul brothers yeah those are
yeah i've only just heard those kids
even though i'm out of touch and they're
like yeah the most faithful world but uh
yeah we had that idea we didn't do it
and now it's the goddamn thing but i
mean you guys still came out okay yeah
yeah
but do you do you think i should just
like put cameras everywhere and just be
like hey guys like i this is what i'm
doing today at least for the patreon at
least for the patreon i think now now is
the time for the actual sketchups yeah i
think that's the next movie after
impractical joker sketch hots yeah
sketchups sketchups i think that's the
next move
who moves in
i mean the guys you got to be young
though it's a young man's game why don't
you do a gal why don't you do a thing
why don't you do a thing the search for
the next and practical jokers the next
young guys who can who can do what you
guys do and that's the part of the
sketch house and they have to come in
there they have to come into that house
and they have to do things you give them
all freaking earpiece you line them all
up and you say
you do what we did and you pick the best
ones of course you know checking boxes
of diversity and sexuality included and
that's what you have to do i think
that's the move for sketch house what do
you think pimp let's do it
let's just do it do you know it'd be so
funny if we rented a home right like an
airbnb or something like that and then
just us we put out casting notices or
get people we know whatever and then we
film our own
dating show in the home i would like
like straight up not over produce the
exact opposite like real [ __ ] yeah like
just real [ __ ] we're like we're making
people like go out to eat talk to each
other like we just do it it's like as
for better or for worse as low rent as
it is
like a diy
bachelor i
interested you know i'm interested i
would love to do it where like they go
out and then yeah ahead of time we we
think about what the format of the show
is what the formula we're not duping
anybody the amount of things that go
wrong on dates yeah i mean that's and
that a and right there that already that
one show idea alone pays for the sketch
house content house right yeah i don't
know it seems like a big undertaking but
seems like it'll be fun but why the hell
not why can't we do we'll do a live from
the panic room
should we go live from the panic room
for our next for the first live
specialized really cool live in the
panic room yeah panic at the room like
panic at the disco i like that how do
you know about panic at the disco oh i
love panic at the disco really
absolutely
panic at the disco is one of my favorite
bands of all time i wouldn't peg you for
that i love i love getting pegged do you
ever have a goth phase i feel like
chris's panic at the disco my chemical
romance i loved yeah i love them well
the 1975 is my favorite band right but
but but i love my chemical romance and
panic at the disco i love panic at the
disco i loved
paramore
paramore i love yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah wow you surprised me i love all
those i didn't know you know who they
were now this is hot have you guys ever
painted your nails
that's what the wrappers are doing
they're just everyone's wearing nail
polish even bobby lee had his nails
painted
in the beginning of quarantine my
daughter at she said paint i want to
paint your nails and then by the you
can't bite your nails and you can't get
the nail polish off and by the time the
nail polish is off
quarantine and this whole thing will be
over right daddy i said absolutely it's
got to be and that was two years ago
yeah i think i've painted my nose have
you ever had a phase
that wasn't this
like i've seen your you look a little
different when you're younger you know
your face changes and stuff but your
hair was a little shorter but you kind
of still look
like
in this wheelhouse no why don't you ever
have a phase that you look completely
different than this when i was 16 years
old i had cornrows
i had full braided cornrows you can you
can you is there any way to get a
picture i i don't have anything on my
phone digitally but i can't joke or as
serious oh i genuinely thought like i
used to get my hair braided like i i
just i was i just no you didn't i swear
i got my hair braided multiple times i
did yeah because i had really really
long hair you look like allen iverson
like allen iverson i would my hair
braided i used to wear fubu clothing i
swear to god i was literally that white
kid no you weren't i was how do i not
know this i mean you walk the streets
well here with cornrows yeah here i got
one picture
i got one picture look you had cornrows
and listen to whitney houston yeah i
mean there's one picture of me wearing
like a dallas cowboy yeah
yeah
i mean i gotta find i'll find it i'll
send it
you you have the unmitigated goal to
never bring this up and never throw a
photo our way the listeners i want to
see this i just the clothes
no cornrows but i mean i used to dress
like that i used to wear dallas cowboy
that was a little kid yeah that's you 14
15 years old yeah
with a name played on with a dion
sanders jersey and a and a skully cap
i'll send it to people i am
my balls
of smithereen bbo first of all this
doesn't look like you you look like a
small spanish child that's me you look
like a gang banger yes
you you literally look like
a kid right now that just gang bangs on
the street yes
you see that coming you better get in
your panic room i can't believe you're
wearing you you you're probably 60
pounds wearing a size 48 jersey you have
a gold shane you have to show pimp that
yeah yeah
who do you think you are i don't look
like you're in another bad creation i'm
sending it to right now and and that kid
right there was listening at that time
to
whitney houston mariah carey in sync but
i was coming out dressed like that as a
new york giants fan with a dion sanders
dallas cowboys jersey and a skull cap
and a skull cap with a name plate on
this you gotta lose i just texted them i
texted the pimp um
yeah that's how i roll
oh my god can you believe that
horrifying horror you literally look
like you're in crisscross you look like
riffraff i know you know what i'm gonna
do you know what i'm gonna do we're
gonna post that picture one of the show
one show i do i'm gonna come dressed as
that if you want to come see me christy
chris d chrisdcomedy.com we got uh we
just put irvine california up there we
finally got shows up in l.a irvine
california is up there in september we
got uh zany's nashville in october
pittsburgh in october foxwoods fox
theater in october that's a big big one
we got all these shows coming up newark
new jersey
phoenix arizona west palm beach and
dania improv in in southern florida we
got southern florida covered christy
comedy.com come check it out i will
dress in a scully cap in an oversized
jersey one of those shows that's a
promise
i love that i love that uh also on the
road i am we are full tours on sale
right now me and the guys are coming to
a city near you they're all on sale
right now it's 50 cities-ish i'm not
gonna name them all it's uh
the tenderloins.com
tour to get tickets they're all on sale
right now november 19th is the first
date we're going all the way through
august if you don't see your city more
cities will be announced check that out
right now and i will be announcing my
solo tour
shortly i'll probably have to do an
insert for the solo tour because yeah
yeah that's fine all right and um and
yeah man so uh uh you know there's only
um only one thing left to do
this has been hey
baby don't run away from your feelings
bae don't be afraid don't be ashamed
don't hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey